hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast Ana ah just checking in on you
[ __ ] Jesus Christ
it is 348 in the morning a little
jet-lagged here knocking out the podcast
I just did two shows on would be Tuesday
and Wednesday here in Liverpool and at
the Liverpool Philharmonic they had a
little drum kit back there I didn't have
any earplugs I didn't realize that they
were gonna give me one so messed around
on it a little bit but the [ __ ]
crowds were amazing all of my jokes
seemed to be working on this side of the
pond
there were a couple of things that I had
to make minor adjustments to one of the
lines people don't get but I'm leaving
it in the [ __ ] special anyways I
don't give a [ __ ] but this thing's ready
to go I am very excited very relaxed I'm
in a great place and I want to thank
everybody who came out on a school night
Tuesday and Wednesday I could not have
had a better time and thank you to Chris
cans who opened up for me I had a great
time working with him he [ __ ] killed
both shows which I always like I hate
doing a show where you know I like it
wire-to-wire everybody does a good job
so there's none of that bathroom break
[ __ ] while people are on stage you
know so underrated Liverpool beautiful
goddamn City they also helped that the
weather was perfect I guess you know
it's usually gloomy and raining around
these parts but we got two sunny days
and tonight Liverpool had a game and
people still came out to my show which
was very flattering and I kind of got
all back into the whole Premier League
[ __ ] as Liverpool won so I guess you get
three points for winning and last I
checked they would like
one point ahead of man City all right
now this is what's interesting Liverpool
is backed by American dollars
all right man City is backed by Saudi
and a Saudi Arabian money now we buy oil
from Saudi Arabia so in a lot of a bunch
of it so in a lot of ways they're also
in a roundabout way backed by American
dollars but for what I heard rumor has
it is we got more oil in our country at
this point than they do so I don't know
how to do this [ __ ] math all I know
is the owner of the Red Sox owns
Liverpool and you do realize how [ __ ]
insane it would be if the owner of the
Red Sox owned him right through the
curse of the babe ended that curse and
from what I heard Liverpool has never
won the premier championship there's ten
[ __ ] games left
so all they got to do is keep winning
there's no playoffs which playoffs which
blows my mind because they're leaving so
much money on the table like Who am I as
an employer my thing Who am I is an
American this is what Americans do
it's what [ __ ] English people do you
barge in and you [ __ ] put your own
ideas and somebody else's foreign land
so why not
you guys got to have a playoff this is
like college football all over again
everybody would [ __ ] at the end of the
[ __ ] year it's a little bit different
that's actually it's a lot different it
actually kind of makes sense but I don't
know call me a stupid American but they
had a [ __ ] playoff like what it what
if you know if you play all [ __ ] year
and you lose by one point so you don't
get the championship you're one point
less let's say it ended today in
Liverpool beats Man City by one point
what if they just [ __ ] had one more
game the top two teams what if they had
a special thing that if the top two
if you're within five [ __ ] points if
you're in second place by five points or
less
you've earned a playoff game and they
play a one game winner takes [ __ ] all
all right you're gonna tell me like how
many [ __ ] people are gonna tune in
for that
you don't said having all these [ __ ]
games going on at the same time hey Bill
you know I don't know if you've noticed
but the league's pretty [ __ ] me
successful we we really don't need your
[ __ ] ideas I don't know sorry I just
grew up with playoffs playoffs so
anyways that's [ __ ] was pretty
exciting and the next time I really got
into it you know everybody was walking
around today with their scarves on I saw
this guy with the suit on he was going
to work but he still had a white shirt
on with the red tie
clearly like supporting his team like
people were [ __ ] into it it killed me
it killed me to not go to that game
obviously I did a had a great time doing
the show but like just to know that that
was right there most I was playing and
he's [ __ ] like the Wayne Gretzky a
soccer right now then I'd have a chance
to see another great athlete live next
time I come back I'm gonna be drinking I
figure I'll do a one-off show here the
day before the day after probably the
day after would be better if there was a
game right no wait do the show first and
then then I do the game then I get all
banged up and I go to the [ __ ] game
and I put a bunch of money on Liverpool
that way I'll give a [ __ ] I still don't
understand why the defense is allowed to
stop [ __ ] running and then you're
offsides and if that's the case why
don't you just put four fat ladies back
on defense they can't [ __ ] run and
then they never get near your net right
just have them sitting down in the grass
playing with the [ __ ] daisies I don't
get it
whatever somebody will explain it to me
so I got to tell you about a little
medical episode that I had so I flew
over here from New York City
I don't remember fight I was so [ __ ]
up I don't remember I even told you this
did I did I already tell the story about
almost faint well I figured out why I
almost fainted in the elevator right I
already told you this duster I told it
on Monday recap real quickly is I the
day after I flew from New York to LA I
mean to uh to Manchester took the train
over to Liverpool
they had a [ __ ] steam and they had a
sauna and I went to the sauna and I was
in there and I wasn't sweating I'm just
like and didn't feel hot I'm like what
the [ __ ] thing sucks and then I went
to the steam and I was like alright this
is better and then when I left I had to
walk up a flight of stairs when I got to
the elevator like dude I almost went
down like the closest I've come to
fainting ever other than from alcohol
just doing a [ __ ] faceplant so I was
blaming their sauna thinking it was that
[ __ ] that heats you up from the inside
and I didn't realize how [ __ ] hot I
was but when I told a few people what
happened it was I was dehydrated from I
don't think I drank enough water when I
was in New York so I was already a
little dehydrated then I got on a seven
hour [ __ ] six and a half seven hour
flight and then didn't drink water and
then took a sauna and a [ __ ] steam so
and then all my symptoms like I [ __ ]
when I went to the locker room was by
myself and all of a sudden I was like oh
my god I got a [ __ ] sit down and then
I was like dry heaving and I was like oh
my god what the [ __ ] I'm gonna puke and
then I didn't puke and there was nobody
in the locker room and then after that
then all of a sudden it wanted to come
out the other end not to get [ __ ]
gross but uh it did and I think that
toilet is retired and so many Tony said
all of these are signs of you were
dehydrated you're dehydrated I saw I was
too hydrated before I took a [ __ ]
sauna and a steam and my dumb ass almost
[ __ ] passed out did I tell you this
story I can't remember no wait I didn't
I didn't that's right because I had to
show that night and when I did this show
there was a couple times
when I ramped up the energy and I was
like touching my toes doing something I
came back up fast I was like oh [ __ ] am
I gonna pass out right here on stage
dude I got on the [ __ ] elevator and
this other guy going on with me and I
was just leaning on the [ __ ] like I'm
rested of the rail and I was just
staring at the ground and you know that
deal when you think you're gonna faint
and you're just trying to keep yourself
cool and every time you think he hit the
top like okay I can deal with this I can
maintain my consciousness it goes a
little higher and you like I'll [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] hang in there and I can't
remember if the dude was talking to me
or not I think he said something people
when I got off I got off at the wrong
floor so I had to walk down a flight of
stairs and I got to the first set of
first step and just sat down and then
the guy looked at me he goes are you
okay alright now if I was a woman I
would be like no I need help I have a
family and a child that's depending on
me to not die right but I'm a man so of
course I said yeah I'm fine
dude I was I was not fine and he you
know he's a guy so he's like all right
well this is emotionally weird to deal
with this with another guy and he just
[ __ ] left so I sat on the [ __ ]
stairs for like I don't know like
another like minute and I slowly walked
down the stairs and I just I made it
into the the hotel room and at that
point I I asked club soda Kenny I just
texted him said bring me a Gatorade and
some [ __ ] waters and [ __ ] so I just
pounded that and I was alright but Jesus
Christ old freckles almost went down all
freckle okay here's one for you if
you're a [ __ ] dumbass like me and you
get on a plane and fly for six hours
more or more and you're already
dehydrated yet don't go take a [ __ ]
sauna and then - I took two steams cuz I
was like that son is not doing [ __ ] now
when I went into the steam room I
thought I was sweating it was just the
[ __ ] steam and then I went back in
again [ __ ] idiot
but other than that I had a great time
here
you know checked out the Beatle statue I
did a couple of like touristy things but
other than that I just tried to walk
around look at a lot of beautiful
buildings and everything really really
great city and the people were cool as
[ __ ] and I kept striking out with the
food though Jesus Christ I ate at this
[ __ ] Italian place what kind of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] gets Italian in
Liverpool England I went I ordered these
[ __ ] I got some oysters because you
know I'm trying to keep my figure for my
special so I wanted some oysters okay
and I'm thinking you know there's water
right here these oysters got to be fresh
did that taste fresh at all and then I
got one of those those uh you know those
rice balls tines make it's like it's
[ __ ] rice it's almost like risotto
it's got like cheese in it and then they
deep-fried it's [ __ ] that was my
little that was my cheap meal all right
so I order those things it shows up with
like truffles on it it was the blandest
I never send back food and I just don't
have the [ __ ] courage to do it cuz
you guys send me in stories about
sending back food and like what happens
because I'm always of the belief they're
gonna get mad at you and then they're
gonna spit on your food but like these
[ __ ] things were so bad there was
like there was no fix in it you know
what I mean it's not like oh hey this is
medium rare could you make it medium
it's just like this tastes like the
person who cooked it doesn't know how to
cook is this bring your [ __ ]
six-year-old to work day and they
[ __ ] made my rice balls here and I
just was like you know what I'm not
[ __ ] eat this is this is how
rebellious this is the most rebellious
I've ever been in a restaurant because I
worked in one and I never was tip well
even if they [ __ ] suck so I I ate one
of them and I was just like I am NOT
going to out of politeness and how my
parents raised me to not waste food eat
these other five [ __ ] things and then
have to get on an elliptical and work
off something that I didn't even enjoy
so I just set it to the [ __ ] side and
ate my fish oysters and the waitress
came back around and she goes okay she's
like
was everything and I said what I always
say great it was all great it was
awesome and she's looking clearly seeing
that I barely touched it she goes
everything was fine and I was like yeah
it's great I just get the check and that
was it so the upside is it with being
dehydrated and almost puking and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] eating this [ __ ] food over
here I've actually dropped some pounds
of course laying off the booze doesn't
hurt either
so anyways is another thing I learned by
the way I'm just keep saying anyways cuz
I can't stop saying it
I like to think it's part of my charm
I've always wanted to go to that TT race
since I found out it about about six
seven years ago and I keep trying to
book myself on the Isle of Man and they
just don't have shows there I don't know
what the deal is well they don't know
who I am and they don't give a [ __ ] I
don't know what it is and I just
realized today looking at the map that
Liverpool is like forty five [ __ ]
minutes flight away so I'm thinking of
maybe at some point doing a one-off show
here and flying over and seeing that
race before you know people who don't
race motorcycles and don't watch
motorcycle racing are so outraged by it
that they shut it down you know those
are the same [ __ ] people who try to
get fighting out of hockey and they just
they just try to ruin any sort of
gladiator thing that is left in society
you know what I mean oh the latest dead
person that people have been going after
they went after John Wayne now they just
what they went after I think Bill Hicks
it's the stupidest [ __ ] ever all these
white people trying to show how [ __ ]
progressive they are by keeping the
limelight off of them and all the
mistakes they've made socially in their
lives but now they're I think they've
attacked all the white people they can
get that are alive now they're going
after dead people dead white people
apparently Davy Crockett was a piece of
[ __ ]
I just don't how is that helping
anything you know not to mention it's an
astoundingly white thing to do to think
that you have to go back in history to
find people like that and then it's up
to you to redefine how we are perceiving
these five why don't you deal with what
the [ __ ] going on now that's another
really cringe-worthy thing you know when
people I can't believe in 2019 well
that's because you're white um sorry
it's just I don't if these [ __ ] lefty
Whitey's patting themselves on the
[ __ ] back you know with all of this
[ __ ] you know acting like they're
[ __ ] doing something it's like listen
if you want to get involved there's
plenty of groups that you can join that
go and just you can physically take time
out of your [ __ ] life to go do
something stop [ __ ] I don't know I'm
just you know remember that guy used to
do the [ __ ] humble brags the guy
passed away if he was still around here
maybe he would do another one that had
to do with humble bragging but like it's
in like a social way won't bragging or
some [ __ ] I don't know what it is so
anyways I actually miss I misunderstood
when the when the the thing for Brody
was gonna be Brody Stephens it's gonna
be I don't why I'm announcing this thing
here cuz it's just for family and
comedians they're gonna shut down the
Comedy Store they're shutting the whole
[ __ ] thing down not making any money
that night this is what this guy meant
to the Comedy Store and everybody that
knew and loved him they're shutting down
the entire [ __ ] comedy club March
11th and we're gonna have a big night
remembering him telling stories and all
that it's gonna be [ __ ] unbelievable
and I feel so thankful that I'm actually
gonna be in town when this goes down and
I can't wait to to go down there and be
a part of that and what else did I want
to say about that I can't [ __ ]
remember him [ __ ] half half asleep
here oh yeah I was also able to call him
Brody you know
obviously did a podcast for the all
things comedy Network and I was talking
to one of the people over there and they
said today that over 100 say that again
100 people showed up to be on his final
podcast all went over drove themselves
over there called in i Skyped in and it
just really goes to show you like I you
know I I don't think I've ever seen that
you know unfortunately I've seen a lot
of people pass away but like this guy
really touched a lot of people so you
know if he can take a positive out of
something so [ __ ] sad that is that
would definitely be it so I imagine at
this point if I actually had the
advertising I would read some so I'm
just going to say hey I'm going to the
the advertising now and this is where we
will edit it and all right and now we're
back we're back to the podcast here what
else is there to talk about I'm going to
Glasgow now what I love about Glasgow
aside from the fact that I love I love
Scotland is I'm a huge ac/dc fan and old
ac/dc fans like myself all know that the
live album if you want blood you got it
was recorded in Glasgow and I have for
years would listen to that song the jack
and when bond scott sang she told me she
was a virgin he would say something I
couldn't I any virgins whatever I could
never understood stand what he was
saying he was actually saying any
virgins in Glasgow Glasgow I believe
that's what he's saying and I never then
when I finally went I thought it was
Glasgow so I wasn't saying it right then
I went there and I heard how they said
it Glasgow all of a sudden it just
clicked on my head going wait a minute
he's this with a [ __ ]
so of course I had to figure out where
the theater was that they recorded it
and I'm like I got a [ __ ] play there
I gotta tell my [ __ ] jokes we're the
greatest rock band as far as I'm
concerned rock and roll band ever
performed one of the greatest rock Alive
rock albums ever and unfortunately I
looked it up and it was it no longer
exists speaking of which when you come
in to Liverpool they have the club where
the Beatles played like 200 shows like
some of their first 200 shows and now
that I am an experienced tourist I said
to the driver I said now is this the
original place is this the exact place
because I remember when I was in London
everybody does a stupid Abbey Road thing
where you walking across the street I
want to be John I want to be Paul that's
not the same crosswalk the crosswalk has
been moved so you're not standing where
they stood okay so I asked I'm like okay
now that [ __ ] crosswalk [ __ ] I
did that and it turned out that they
[ __ ] you know that wasn't where they
were now is this club really the place
where John Paul Ringo and George all
played their first 200 shows that the
cavern club or something like that and
the guy goes he's like yeah now know it
isn't a place where they originally
played it's like a [ __ ] hotel now but
this is close it's on the street so the
best thing you can do is you can walk
down the street where they walked to go
to a club that no longer exists but when
you go into the club that they say is
the club it's not the [ __ ] club oh
did I take a picture I got a I got a I
don't want to [ __ ] hurt anybody's
business here but I was with Andrew
thumbless he sees like shooting stuff
for my patreon page on this tour me
getting ready for my special and we went
to go you know he's a huge Beatles fan
so we went down there and we would check
it out all of these
come on did I take a picture of it [ __ ]
I didn't take a picture god damn it we
went to this this Beatles museum okay
now if you're trying to attract people
it's if you have artifacts from the
Beatles what you want to do is have like
a couple of you not you have your best
ones you want to keep your best ones in
there also it's a letdown but you got to
put something from your top five out
front so we go to walk into this [ __ ]
Museum because I want to go in and I was
like alright alright and he goes you
don't wanna go and I go listen to it
you're [ __ ] huge Beatle fans I want
to ruin this for you let's [ __ ] go in
so we go to walk up the steps to go in
and I swear to god they have this
mannequin that they dressed like John
Lennon and it was just a mannequin and
it had the all white suit that he had
and it wasn't the white suit it was just
a white suit and they glued afar taped a
beard to a mannequins face and put this
awful [ __ ] wig on it looked like me
when I dress up to do the Comedy Jam and
I just started laughing and I was just
like Andrew I go look at this [ __ ]
thing if this is what they have to get
you in there what the [ __ ] do they have
in there and he just started laughing
and we were just like god [ __ ] let's
get out of here so I think I think we
made the right move on that one but they
did have a lot of cool stuff and we went
to another place had a bunch of cool
t-shirts and [ __ ] I tried to find
something for my daughter I actually
couldn't find anything but I got to get
her something but um I am excited in a
couple of days because I'm flying home
you know my family over here and I can't
wait to see my kiddo
I signed up for Skype and that's been a
good thing so I talked to her like three
times a day and uh yeah she's hilarious
but it's just killing me the stuff I'm
missing like this morning my wife was
putting socks on her and they had a
little teddy bear on it and she pointed
it and she goes teddy bear and my wife
was surprised because she didn't know
she could say that and she goes my wife
goes that's right teddy bear and then my
daughter just put her right hand up and
she goes
high-five like [ __ ] Borat and my wife
said she [ __ ] like oh like just
keeled over laughing and what's awesome
is my daughter like she understands that
shit's funny now so now it's the cutest
thing ever she laughs and after she left
she goes funny it's just it's the
greatest thing ever and it's killing me
that I'm out here so thank you to
whoever invented Skype and FaceTime and
all that so that's that's been helping
me out but I'm coming down to the end of
it here I got a I got a killer new hour
that I'm very proud of and I can't wait
to [ __ ] and unleash this and let it go
and then just see you know you know
where the next hour leads me and with
that I got to give a shout-out here to
an amazing musician I saw tonight
Victoria Sharpe I was in this cigar bar
I wasn't gonna smoke a cigar before my
special but I had I kind of gave in I
just had to go have one you know they
this great place puffin rooms here in
Liverpool and this woman Victoria Sharpe
sha RPE her Instagram is at Victoria
Sharpe sha RPE music and she was on the
piano and like she was so [ __ ] good
it sounded like she was in the other
room because they didn't want have her
in that playing piano everybody was
smoking so she was in the smoke-free
section and she's playing it you know
she came around and she had this whole
list of songs anything any songs like
[ __ ] like 200 [ __ ] songs it seems
and she just went in and I didn't
realize she started playing and after
they just sounded like the same artists
over and over again I finally if the
guys I was with I was like is that that
woman was just talking to it was so good
it sounded like I'd like a recording
she actually one point saying happy
birthday did this do Jamie who came out
to the show and she's saying it's so
good I actually that's the first time I
ever been like yeah happy birthday it's
a really good song like she made happy
birthday sound like a [ __ ] hit song
so if you ever get a chance to see her
check out our music she's on you
to Graham at Victoria sharp with an e at
Victoria sharp music check her out and I
mean she seems like she'd be perfect too
if you have a private party and you just
want a killer musician that just plays
piano and can just crush it doing that
it's not intrusive but it adds to the
atmosphere can't say enough good things
about her and she was cool as [ __ ] when
I met her alright so anyways thank you
to everybody who came out here in
Liverpool could not have had a great
better time it was a [ __ ] honor to be
here and looking forward to going back
to Scotland been to Glasgow a couple of
times haven't been in a while so those
[ __ ] lunatics Scottish people are
[ __ ] lunatics I love them so then
after that we go to Manchester then I
think Birmingham and then it's off to
London that old freckles does is special
I'm getting really [ __ ] excited for
this so that's it enjoy the music and
then we have a half hour away it's
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast and Thursday from
bye last year five years ago
[Music]
beyond movie scenes the
Donnie the one dream alive from all past
even through the every life
45 well
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday
February 28th 2011 and that's it for
this month pay your [ __ ] rent still
tomorrow alright all you pot heads out
there sitting on the couch man whoa is
it like February
I like making fun of pothead say thank
you they're really [ __ ] defensive
individuals every once a while I make
fun of pot heads on here when I get a
plethora of emails speaking of emails if
you'd like to send an email to the
podcast sent it to bill at the mmm
podcast calm that's the new email bill
be I B isn't Bill I ll at the mmm
podcast calm alright and yeah I make fun
of the [ __ ] pot heads I make fun of
them I was actually having I mean I
don't give a [ __ ] if you do it or not
I don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
if that's your ritual that's what you
have to do do what you having a beer and
smoke gonna join at the end of the day
huh why don't you answer that one there
freckle-faced I'll tell you what the
difference is what I'm doing is legal
what you're doing is don't you throw
your pot smoking [ __ ] hands in the
air let me finish my point all right you
hemp shirt wearing [ __ ] yeah
that's the difference that's the only
difference because I don't even think
like as far as health goes I was gonna
say health wise but that that word
doesn't exist I remember from my vocab
improvement class way back in high
school this guy used to talk about the
wiseguys health-wise sports-wise
weather-wise the wiseguys that those
words do not exist although lately
ladies lately the dictionaries just said
[ __ ] it you know we can't keep up with
the overwhelming level of stupid people
using words that we say don't exist and
then they just give in you know like
they'll make lol
like a legitimate word an abbreviation B
they laugh out loud
initially sleet or the Internet in 2003
they'll do [ __ ] like that you know
that's a bad example but then again I'm
not exactly a great host all right you
want something better go to another
[ __ ] podcast I don't need you your
attitudes the hell was I talking about
oh I was talking about weed the
difference the difference I was talking
to a buddy of mine last night we were
out in a sports bar
we're actually watched the the Celtics
Clippers great game and it's awesome to
see the Clippers are good and I'm also
really really really nervous about
getting rid of Kendrick Perkins I don't
get that I just felt a big sigh of
relief from everybody on the on the
Lakers bench oh thank God we don't have
to deal with that guy [ __ ] making us
be men you know bitch-slapping us and
it's [ __ ] paint like we deserve
that's why Pau Gasol's face is so
[ __ ] thin he took a slap from Perkins
on both side of his hey game a double
remember killer Khan he gave him one of
those during the first time we met him
in the finals then he had that deer in
the eye look for the rest of the [ __ ]
series that's what happened oh yeah we
traded him away but don't get too
excited Laker fans cuz I got a feeling
those [ __ ] the Thunder are gonna take
you out you know I think you guys are I
think you've you've had your moment
you had your moment the [ __ ] Sun but
don't worry don't worry I heard through
the [ __ ] grapevine that dad
what's-his-face there the goddamn he
looks like one of those transformers was
a guy playing I'm so bad when I want to
talk about who what the [ __ ] is that
Dwight Howard I heard through the
grapevine wants to be a [ __ ] Laker
can you believe that [ __ ]
can you believe that [ __ ] you know can
Kobe have any more championships just
laid at his [ __ ] feet overrated
Kobe Bryant three out of his five
[ __ ] rings [ __ ] yeah no stupid
Laker fans yeah VP
VP anytime he does anything just drives
me up the [ __ ] wolf the guy got Shaq
in his prime with Phil Jackson you know
and all these [ __ ] Laker fans would be
like will Jordan Adam Jordan had him
when he was a [ __ ] nobody with no
experience okay other than as a player
okay he became Phil Jackson with with
with the Bulls you know what I mean you
[ __ ] morons he knew how to win he
knew how to take big stars and molding
together that's what the [ __ ] he got and
that's what he got was Shaq and then he
still pulled the [ __ ] team apart still
pulled him apart I don't know he gets
[ __ ] Dwight Howard [ __ ] him and his
in out the last two championships I
respected all right but those first
three give me a [ __ ] break okay you
take Kobe out of that lineup and you put
me in there and that little [ __ ]
frilly gold and purple uniform with my
ghost white legs we're still gonna win
50 games I'm just gonna be feeding
cheque and he's gonna turn around with
this tongue sticking out the side of his
mouth like some special-needs kid trying
to put blocks in a round circle right
really did you have to attack those
people bill sorry I'm going off the dome
anyways let's get back to [ __ ] pot
here all right this is this is this is
the conversation I had oh I know so um I
went to this this Boston sports bar last
night and for the first time since I can
[ __ ] remember I had a good experience
as a fan because I mean almost you guys
who listen to this you know even it over
there in jolly old England your cozy
smug [ __ ] right if you're a fan of
Liverpool you pretty much live in
Liverpool right isn't that how it police
when you're young but then you move away
and not only do you feel weird rooting
on your team yet people are telling you
that they suck it did it's unreal since
1995 I moved to New York City and then
it went from everybody loving the Red
Sox to absolutely hating their existence
and then I moved out to LA and everybody
hates the Celtics and not to mention the
awful vibe of sports fans out here
on the west coast they are [ __ ]
horrific I don't know why ESPN spends
the lion's share of their time when they
talk about awful fans just talking about
Philly
you know just recycling those same two
[ __ ] stories about Santa Claus and I
don't know what else they did they
[ __ ] what did they do then they rape
like Kathie Lee Gifford so now what
happened I can't [ __ ] remember anyways
um yeah just out here the vibe it's just
not fun out here I don't know I can't
explain it it's like back east
obnoxious shit-talking morons
right and I include myself as one of
those but eventually it dies down and
you'll start talking about the game
you'll start talking about games you
went to you start talking sports it goes
beyond hey [ __ ] you you [ __ ] chatter
eatin fig it goes beyond that
out here it never does and when it does
it goes on - I'll stab you in the
parking lot it's not fun out here I
guess I don't know what it is I don't
know what it is there's that I will stab
you in the [ __ ] people get stabbed at
games out here hilarious like that movie
the Warriors it's [ __ ] ridiculous
you UCLA and USC played at the Rose Bowl
okay and people got stabbed and they're
talking about Philly because they threw
batteries at Santa Claus what would you
rather have would you rather be dressed
like a holiday icon taking a [ __ ]
Duracell to the head or would you rather
take a steak knife to the gut through
your game-worn Jersey out in the parking
lot to bleed out on the [ __ ] 17th
hole outside of the Rose Bowl I don't
[ __ ] know so anyways can I can I say
why I like what am I don't I'm saying
you know you're a stuttering prick so I
went to this went to this sports bar
that was just a Boston sports bar and it
was [ __ ] great
like the Celtics did some
good and I was almost self-conscious to
chair I'm so beaten down by living out
here and everybody was going nuts and
was just such a [ __ ] relief it was
awesome and I've decided [ __ ] Staples
Center I'm not going to the games down
there even Dodgers games are
surprisingly not fun I had a buddy of
mine showed up to a Dodgers game they
were playing some other National League
team and he's from Cleveland he had a
Cleveland Indians hat on
he's out in the bleachers and this guy
started like legitimately saying I'm
gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you if you
don't take that Cleveland Indians hat
off [ __ ] Indians they have won since
1948 who gives a [ __ ] so anyways [ __ ]
I'm never gonna get back to the weed
here I'm gonna have to stick with this
[ __ ] story so last week cuz you know
I cut the podcast short because I
someone hooked me up and I went to the
to the all-star game to go down there
and watch some of the greatest athletes
on the planet and of course check out
the who is and I was not disappointed
[ __ ] amazing basketball and the level
of horror just every [ __ ] tear ok the
desperate horror the horror lived down
the [ __ ] Street all the way up to the
[ __ ] who flew in for the [ __ ] game
who's been doing p90x for the last
[ __ ] eight months you know did some
sort of cleanse and was just an
unbelievable shape just [ __ ] trying
to figure out how to get in to an
after-party to get into the hotel and it
was [ __ ] awesome so anyways i get i
get this insane hookup right I'm not
trying to big-league you guys here
alright but I got it I got a great I got
a great [ __ ] hookup and I was in one
of those one of the luxury boxes one of
the 90 million luxury boxes that they
have at Staples Center they have like
three three levels of them and I'm
sitting there and I'm like oh finally
I'm in Staples Center it's not a Lakers
game it's not a Clippers game and I
playing the Celtics I don't listen to
Boston sucks the entire time I'm here
right and all of a sudden I know a
second is that my phone can you hear
that where the [ __ ] is my phone
here that gay little ring that's my
phone where is it bum bubble bum bum
bubble bum anybody else had the [ __ ]
Droid yeah that don't done the reason
why I picked that is because there's
like 10 options for a ringtone on the
Droid and the first nine sound like an
air raid
you know bad bad bad or they take that's
this ringing that just it just puts me
on edge so the only thing like that
one's called waterfall so I have it set
on that every time I do Nia goes what
are you a fake but I say I like that one
so anyways so I got box seats for the
[ __ ] all-star game it's ridiculous
right I'm sitting there and I got a hold
Lee no I bought like an all-star t-shirt
and you know total [ __ ] nerd fan and
I go to the game I'm thinking this is
great so finally have to deal with [ __ ]
talk of people right sitting there
watching the game and all of a sudden
this little kid voice seven eight year
old when when Doc Rivers put out the big
three from the Celtics I just start
hearing this kid going anytime a Celtics
shoot the ball he go brick
yelling this [ __ ] right the entire
[ __ ] time ago you got to be [ __ ]
me you got to be [ __ ] me really
you're gonna heckle at a [ __ ] all-star
game you idiot right and then they go to
sit the big three from the Celtics right
and then I hear this guy's voice go go
sure boys dude I'm like what kind of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yells at at an all-star
game and I look over I'm not gonna say
who it was but it was a rapper very
famous rapper who was transcended being
just a rapper you know has traveled the
[ __ ] world and I'm literally sitting
there going because I was looking at the
kid going this kid sounds like a 35 year
old [ __ ] you know who calls in like a
sports talk radio kind of thing why
behaving that way and then I look Oh cuz
his dad is an [ __ ]
hey wait it just said I'll just cut in
and ended up you know the experienced
end up sup but I will give this to them
at least they weren't they were making
some noise I don't you guys watch the
all-star game it was the worst crowd
I've ever seen in my life
the problem was because the entire lower
level was either former players [ __ ]
or some form of celebrity or somebody
managing a celebrity and everybody just
sat there I mean I could have yelled
from where I was sitting and someone on
the court could have [ __ ] heard me
but I don't know I still like that
rappers albums at least the stuff from
the late 80s Early 90s you're eventually
gonna figure this out but Jesus Christ
do you ever have the urge to throw an
eight-year-old off a [ __ ] mezzanine
level I didn't want to do that but you
know it's just like will you shut the
[ __ ] up just shut up all of you awliyas
shut up honey can make a [ __ ] layup
just shut up already it's a [ __ ]
all-star game so anyways let's get back
to the weed let's get back to the weed
so so I go to this sports bar and I'm
hanging out and we started talking about
you know I'm still not boozing right 135
[ __ ] days here people this is getting
serious you know this is like I sort of
hung out with somebody in a cult and
you're like at bills too smart for this
[ __ ] you know and then one day I show up
with the shaved head and that glass
Tovar look at my eye talking about
waiting for the spaceship I'm a hundred
thirty five [ __ ] days in people I
don't know if I'm coming back now you
[ __ ] booze hounds out there I think
you might have lost me god you're still
there so anyway so we were talking about
the difference between you know booze
versus weed and and I thought basic Dom
I said yeah I don't think there's
anything especially now it's like a
vaporizer I don't you know that has to
be way more healthier than drinking like
three beers and that's seriously that's
another thing to like when when pot
heads go like you know you come home
after work you have a beer I smoke a
joint it's like no dude that is
different I drink a beer I'm
drunk you know you smoke a joint that's
like drinking like what three four beers
I think it is anyways whatever so this
is this is what I think the difference
is I think the fact because weed is not
legal that's why it leads to other drugs
you basically you left the legal world
and now you've dipped your toe into
illegal and I think it's really easy to
go from weed to be like a shrooms you
know this is cousin it's no biggie
I have you you know and then there's
this and then cocaine is kind of further
in the back of that room and then right
behind cocaine he's a big steel [ __ ]
door like that maniac used to come out
of in the in the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
'he's you slide that [ __ ] open and in
there that's where heroin meth oxy and
all that [ __ ] is in there alright which
I don't think just cuz you smoke weed
that you go to that but there there
that's what I will say that you know
when when people who smoke weed go do it
it doesn't lead the heart of drugs and
yeah it does I think it does it doesn't
always you know these people who smoke
crack and they don't become addicted
they die I tried it once I was like
whatever and then other people lose
their entire lives there is exception to
appeal but be honest with me pot heads
all right like I got this one I want to
know how many people out there have just
tried just you know been drunk you know
tried alcohol I guess is what I'm trying
to say never tried weed but did try
mushrooms like I've done to drugs
alcohol and mushrooms you know alcohol
and coke like I I bet you would be
hard-pressed to find somebody who
doesn't have weed in there it goes bare
weed shrooms or beer weed coke depending
on what you want to feel right if you
want to hallucinate if you want to feel
like Charlie Sheen huh
how [ __ ] amazing was that whole thing
I loved all day like I'm on Twitter by
the way I finally gave in Joe Rogan
signed me up to drop a [ __ ] name
there
I was doing his awesome podcast which
you guys should all check out I was
doing his podcast he was beside himself
that I wasn't signed up to Twitter and
I've been [ __ ] all over Twitter
tweeting and all that type of thing
saying I don't want to [ __ ] do it and
I'm gradually becoming addicted to it
and of course I don't have will have it
up on the mmm podcast com where I'm
where I'm located I've been you know
I've learned how to attach pictures and
you know I feel like a little schoolgirl
right now I'm all excited I'm cutting
I'm pasting I'm typing socializing ah
[ __ ] what the hell was I talking about
that I feel okay weed coke yeah Texas
Chainsaw Massacre
oh you can't bill what is wrong with
your brain my brain goes and goes in a
straight line if I try to go back I'm
[ __ ] the [ __ ] was I talking about Oh
Charlie Sheen
there we go thank God Charlie Sheen all
right I'm have to start doing this thing
live so I can start taking college just
for that specific thing that when I lose
my train of thought they could just tell
me what the [ __ ] I was talking about or
I could get an assistant you know I
could do something like that Charlie
Sheen I was amazed at the amount of
people that took what he was saying at
face value
Cathy League referred to bring her up
again she was like I thought his
statements were selfish they were
self-centered it was like you don't
think he was high I can't say was high
because that would be slander but what
the [ __ ] why is my voice cracking oh I
know I cuz I was yelling in that sports
bar what the [ __ ] when it's time to
change that guy he sounded like he
sounded okay for the legal department
not say the rug cook he sounded like
somebody high on cocaine you know right
when you're hitting that peak before the
paranoia comes in from what I've heard
not so you guys think that I'm out there
doing coke I can't do it
I'm too [ __ ] paranoid as it is you
know that I'm the [ __ ] right up the
mountain would be would be very short
for me and then it would just go right
down to I think everybody's watching me
I'm gonna go hide in a [ __ ] broom
closet yeah he just sounded like he was
[ __ ] high out of his mind and I was
actually kind of annoyed by the guy
who was interviewing him because I just
felt like he was sort of enabling him
you know and I kind of saw in that lease
I'm totally judging this because who
knows I don't know either one of those
[ __ ] guys but it was like you see how
celebrities OD because people are just
so psyched to be [ __ ] around them
that they look the other way the guy at
one point goes like you know I saw you
the other day you seemed fine you know
we were at your house in your media room
watching Apocalypse Now and yeah you
seemed fine it's like you [ __ ] star
[ __ ] give me a God did your with
Charlie Sheen watching Apocalypse Now in
his media room in his [ __ ] mansion
there's no way you're gonna criticize
him in that moment that would be like me
hanging out with Jimmy Page watching the
song remains the same he's falling down
drunk and he looks at me like a mate you
think I got a drinking problem Jimmy
you're fine hey can i play one of these
good I can half the guitar dude you're
awesome
who the [ __ ] I mean that there's no way
you're gonna criticize anybody you know
if I could go [ __ ] watch The
Godfather over Al Pacino's house well I
guess that's that's not the same because
Charlie Sheen's not in Apocalypse Now
whatever Al Pacino have any kids you
know what the [ __ ] I'm saying I don't
know so whatever I felt bad for the guy
I hope he you know I hope he turns his
life around but I also felt that he I
thought he made some decent points there
was a lot of points and I was just like
hey you know sort of hands on I'm I'm
lying to you actually I only listened to
half that [ __ ] alright before we get
into the podcast here can I tell you
about the [ __ ] at the bank that I ran
into this week oh can you hear it can
you hear it what if [ __ ] is my [ __ ]
phone
what the hell is it alright you guys
really want listen me hunt for my
[ __ ] phone The Hunt for Red October
um alright so I'm sitting outside my
bank you know cuz I worked hard all week
and why would I want the money when I
can just go and give it to these thievin
[ __ ] oh sure I can have it at
home right then I got to worry that
people will figure out that I'm cashing
my checks and I'm bringing them home and
next thing you know the outside of my
apartment
looks like the end scene at the end of
[ __ ] Scarface right a bunch of sweaty
long-haired psychos you know climbing
over my non-existent walls and behind
all of them some guy whose watch walking
is slow is Jason and Friday the 13th
knowing that he's going to get the
[ __ ] kill shot
so anyways I'm sitting outside the bank
and I'm on a conference call you know
talking about some [ __ ] you know
pitching some [ __ ] idea you know
we'll take 10 [ __ ] will stick them in
a house and we'll call it the the
[ __ ] [ __ ] challenge and it [ __ ]
will get [ __ ] Bob Saget the host a
whatever the [ __ ] I was saying right so
as I'm sitting there outside the bank in
the parking lot in my car
there's Holman this lady pulls up in
this Mercedes right and I'm on the phone
she opens the door right into my [ __ ]
car boom doesn't look at my car closes
her car door and just walks into the
[ __ ] Bank and I'm sitting there like
beside myself going did she just open
the car door into my [ __ ] car because
she sort of mind [ __ ] me cuz I heard it
but she didn't do it
or oh my god I'm sorry she didn't look
she just act like it didn't even happen
I was like you know you know the hybrid
cuz it goes from like the gas engine to
the electric engine sometimes when it
when it turns over it causes the car to
shake a little bit and sometimes like
one on one of a podcast that time I
thought that guy rear-ended me that's
what happened so I was like this is that
some sort of hybrid [ __ ] or whatever so
I go back to the phone conversation here
she comes out again and now you know I'm
looking at her you know she's got a
little mid-drift show in you know a
little blondie and I'm like already
starting to judge her and she comes
walking again opens a car door right
into
my car so I'm on this conference call
with like [ __ ] industry people I go
hey can you guys hang on a second I
should have hit mute and I didn't right
so I put I beep the horn I go it I go
hey hey I put the window down she's like
what I go you just opened your door into
my car I did yes
you did it on the way into the bank and
on the way out she's like well I didn't
chip the paint that's what she said
and I was like what you may need an chip
the payee oh you didn't mean look how
would you know why don't you be a little
more considerate next time and look what
the hell are you doing boom and I
slammed the door shut right so I go back
to the car go sorry about that guys I
let's go right oh man that built no it
isn't alright you heard what happened
you [ __ ] jerk you don't have any you
know you don't have any you know
confrontations right so she goes uh then
I just hear her with my window up I can
just hear her going she starts doing
that [ __ ] like I'm this [ __ ] like me
getting upset that you opened your
[ __ ] car door into me twice without a
care in the world like my natural
reaction is not supposed to get upset
you know what I mean
I don't know you know I don't believe in
that whole Heaven and Hell [ __ ] but I
think that that episode right there is
you know if there is this whole
judgement that was won in favor me the
fact that I didn't call her a [ __ ] you
know right there you know what I mean
she ends up giving me the finger like
somehow she's been wrong I swear to god
dude I just wanted to take my [ __ ]
passenger side door open it up and
[ __ ] wait like three [ __ ] times
right into a goddamn car and then just
go I didn't check the paint this is why
I didn't two reasons one cuz it was a
broad all right it was a guy I wouldn't
do it because what if he comes over and
beats the [ __ ] out of me who sake who's
kidding who okay you know if you want to
have like a street fight like a brother
on brother fight where we both end
giving each other in you know
simultaneous headlocks going you give
you give I'll have a fight like that but
I you know average random dude I'm not
fighting the guy I'm 42 [ __ ] years
old okay I'm gonna get my ass kicked but
now there was a woman I can't do it
because she could get out of her [ __ ]
car and just start smashing up my car
and there's really nothing I can do to
try and physically stop her because
she's a lady right and that's the first
reason and then the second reason is
I've watched enough sports to realize
that the refs always see the retaliation
they never see the initial thing so it's
like she [ __ ] hits me twice nobody
sees it and then I [ __ ] slam mic and
then I you know I would be later she did
it to me first
and I when I would [ __ ] loose so I
didn't do anything and oh the [ __ ]
thoughts I had after win of wishing I
followed her you know in my quiet hybrid
to wherever the hell she lived and I
wanted to carve into her driver's side
door either [ __ ]
and I was like yeah that's I'm that's
unoriginal I I loved I wanted to carve
in I didn't chip the paint and to the
side or maybe I did chip the paint lol
laughing my ass off oMG or just some
dumb [ __ ] you know what if I you know
you know what kills me if she's out
there you know she probably told the
story later on that day where I would
just I would love to hear her version of
that [ __ ] story how she was the
victim you know it's just I can tell
who's because she was hot and she's not
used to somebody actually calling her on
her [ __ ] or if she's a product of the
combination the timeout generation and
that generation for the last [ __ ] 35
I don't know 35 years for the last I
don't 25 [ __ ] years the parenting at
least in this country I don't know what
happened it's like it went from when I
was a kid where whatever your neighbor
said you did your parents believed
whatever your teacher said you did
whatever an adult said that you were
doing and you were out of a and you were
out of line parents just said oh is that
what he's doing I'm gonna have a talk
with them mr. Robinson down the street
says you jumped over his fence II well
you went you were jumping in his pool
then you tried to light ah
don't give me that [ __ ] get upstairs you
going you [ __ ] row but whatever they
don't do that anymore
the last like 25 years it's like if
somebody says something to somebody hey
basically your kids being a [ __ ]
right now they just automatically defend
their kid straight through the whole
thing they defend their kid you can't go
over somebody's house you got have a
[ __ ] playdate you don't get the [ __ ]
kicked out of you you don't get hit or
anything you get a timeout you know and
then I think you know 25 [ __ ] years
later you're in a bank [ __ ] opening
you goddamn door into somebody's car
you're a surprise that they're mad and B
don't think you did anything [ __ ]
wrong timeout
look at hockey you're going to beat the
[ __ ] out of somebody they just make the
guy sit down for five minutes you know
does he learn anything he comes out he
[ __ ] beats him up hey by the way how
about those Bruins huh beating a very
very very very strong Vancouver Canucks
team I was a big [ __ ] victory for us
but I think before I know and the
[ __ ] road trip dude all right let's
get to the topics for this week topic
number one for the classic is it racist
racist racist Oh before I get into that
before I get into that uh here's
something you might want to read up on
last week when I was talking about the
the the [ __ ] that go to the all-star
game and that type of [ __ ] there's
somebody sent me an article that we will
have linked on the the mm podcast com
was an article that came out in 2006 in
GQ magazine where one of the writers
hung out with some groupies some NBA
groupies and that type of thing and what
is really it's really
article and what is also really
interesting is she never really gets to
talk to any of the [ __ ] that are
really doing the dirt you know what I
mean she talks to three girls who well
we might if it happened but who knows
we're just here to have fun that's how
tight that circle is it's really
interesting article well I'll have to
link up on the mmm podcast com the
official pan fan page of the Monday
morning podcast and now let's get to the
topic is it all right bill while
flipping the channels the other night I
happen to catch the end of America's
Funniest Home Videos America's Funniest
Home Videos the family that won on this
particular night was a white family with
what I assumed was an adopted black
daughter who was maybe six or seven
years old anyways after they announced
the winners the host shook each of the
family members hands but when he got to
the little girl he put his hand up and
asked for a high-five which immediately
made me livid I'm not saying it was
necessarily racist but I hate it when
white people call me brother or want to
give me complicated handshakes when they
barely know me can you please tell your
listeners to knock that [ __ ] off lol you
know what's [ __ ] funny about that is
yeah I agree with you it isn't racist
but it is a annoying sort of pandering
or ingratiating yourself to black
culture yeah I can see like I I know
what you're saying I just don't know how
to verbalize it the only way I can
really describe it is you guys anybody
out there by that p90x I recommend it
it's great I just go on the road so I
can't do the diet so it didn't work for
me but Nia's been doing it lately and
she brought up something I forgot what's
really funny on those tapes I don't I
can't remember the names other people
there but there's like you know a white
guy like two white chicks and then a
black dude so he goes around the room
saying hello to everybody this is Pam
they call her blam alright and he just
you know gonna this is Jerry he's a
Taekwondo guy watch out for this guy you
know this is so and so but blah blah
blah and then he walks up to the black
let's just say his name is like you know
whatever James and he goes hey if you
like what's up James my brother
[Laughter]
every [ __ ] disc he calls him my
brother and then he goes like
high-pitched my brother and it's it's so
douche chills from the Opie and Anthony
leave Opie and Anthony came up with that
expression or that's at least where I
heard it first douche chills
every time I hear that I totally agree
with you I don't think it's racist it's
just some sort of it's like if you met
somebody Asian would you bow
you know that's yeah I get that I get
that that's [ __ ] funny I and I've
been guilty of doing the a semi you know
that the the the handshake the I don't
know the mainstream one was it grabbed
the thumb slide of the hand the snap
thing that thing was there for a while I
died any [ __ ] though but I will not
do a fist bump with anybody even if even
if there's a black guy there I still
won't do it I'll just assume that he's
still hanging out with too many white
people and that's why he's still doing a
pound all right next one hey Bill
I just finished up a conversation on
Facebook with some female friends of
mine long story short I asked if they
were on Twitter they replied we don't
Twitter and I replied all right well
whenever you ladies realize that you're
missing out on the greatest social
network since the Underground Railroad
just follow me at and he wrote his
Twitter name he said what was my comment
racist in your opinion no first of all
you guys you got to let me know what
race you are to so I'm assuming that
you're white now that isn't racist
that's what overly sensitive people
would think that it's racist because you
made a reference to something that
involved they they do this happens to me
a lot and stand-up where people don't
look at the context in which you're
saying something you're basically saying
the Underground Railroad is the greatest
social network or Twitter is the
greatest one since the Underground
Railroad so it doesn't
mean that you think that the Underground
Railroad was a great thing the
Underground Railroad was was Africans as
escape and slavery so no I think it's
actually it's a good reference I think
you're guilty of making a good reference
but if you around a bunch of overly
sensitive people they would immediately
think because you brought up something
that had to do with slavery on some
level that you somehow advocated
advocated slavery that happens a lot in
stand-up where people don't listen to
what you're saying or if you make a
reference to slavery they then think
that well because you made a reference
to it then you obviously advocate it so
no I don't think that that is a I don't
think that that's racist alright let's
plow ahead next one is it bill here's
one for you I'm 35 but when I was about
23 for some reason I went to a bunch of
stores looking for a specific CD CDs
back when they had those things so I
come from a middle-class family and went
to high school high school that was like
nine oh two one oh it was almost
entirely white so I find myself in this
store looking for what I thought was a
CD by Snoop Dogg I felt like an idiot
and I'm standing in there and khakis and
a polo while the other white kid behind
the counter reads a list of available CD
titles by Snoop Dogg as I try to
remember the name that I'm looking for
all right didn't really set that up so
he goes into the store he finds another
white kid who works there he's dressed
in khakis and polos and says that he's
looking for a Snoop Dogg CD so now the
white kid behind the counter is reading
off titles of Snoop Dogg albums he goes
try to imagine him the white kid looking
down at the computer screen and him
reading the title he goes Snoop upside
and then looking at me straight in the
eyes finishing sarcastically with your
head Snoop upside your head I guess was
the name of the album he goes I never
felt so white lol discouraged I leave
for another store across the street in
the mall as I walk in I immediately spot
one of the token black kids that I could
graduated with me
um now right there that that's an
offensive that's offensive to a lot of
people token black kids you know that's
when you go to the all-white school and
then there was like one black kid then
that kids always called the token so
that's offensive all the way to racist
depending on how I would think but
whatever let's plow ahead here so
anyways he sees the you know the one
black kid he basically went to high
school with he said I was like thank God
lol I stop him and say Antoine listen
man listen man he throws in a man I have
a question for you what is the name of
that Snoop Dogg CD with the blah blah
blah song on it of course there was the
awkward what do you ask him you asked me
because I'm black right is the question
he asked and as I'm standing there
stumped for a response he said it's not
stoop it's not Snoop Dogg it's dr. Dre
and the CD is the chronic he said now
feeling like a true idiot I try to make
some ridiculous small talk that's
[ __ ] hilarious I knew I went to the
right source as he confirmed but what
are your thoughts is that racist no no
it's not racist the token black guy
thing I thought of everything you said
was the thing that I would would raise
the red flag where I would if I was in a
conversation with you you know that [ __ ]
where one white guys talking to another
white guy he doesn't know then out of
nowhere something sort of in the gray
area comes into the conversation and
from you know then there's always that
tense moment of like is this gonna take
a [ __ ] right turn down to an unpaved
Road down to a shack no it isn't it's
not racist at all and it was proven
because he knew the [ __ ] answer yeah
that maybe you're guilty of racially
profiling I think you went really
efficient it's not like you didn't try
to ask another white kid he had no idea
and he was a [ __ ]
he almost seemed like he was judging you
because you were you you were you were
buying the music or in general he just
didn't like rap music but you saw the
black dude you went to school with
that's [ __ ] what he asked me because
I'm black you should have said yes what
am I supposed to ask some redneck well
what would happen if I walked up to you
and asked hey what's with something
having that new Travis Tritt album
he probably like what the [ __ ] you
asking a black guy that question for you
know if somebody came out to me and said
hey Bill what's the name of that beer
that that's famous that Ireland makes I
wouldn't get offence I wouldn't get
offended by that you know or if they
assume that I drank because I'm Irish
even though I'm mostly German all right
but but because I have I don't get
offended when people assume that I'm
mostly Irish I mean it's not like I
don't look like a [ __ ] leprechaun I
think that that falls into being overly
sensitive but I feel that guy's entitled
to considered considering he seemed like
he was the only black guy in school and
other white kids referred to him as the
token and despite all that he was still
nice enough to tell you what CD to buy
see that that had a nice warm fuzzy
ending all right another one dear bill
hey by the way my breeding is getting a
lot better
I got a pat myself on the back pat pat
myself in the back my speaking still
sucks oh dear bill I recently moved to
downtown Denver from Fort Collins oh
Jesus is that up near Greeley Colorado
where they have the bad smell day I know
I've talked about this before in the
podcast but just in case there's new
listeners out there in Greeley Colorado
they have a slaughterhouse up there
where you know if you ever wondered
where your [ __ ] hamburgers and steaks
and all that [ __ ] came from Greeley
Colorado is a good guess and some days
when it's really windy up there and
they've murdered a bunch of [ __ ]
steer they have what's known as bad
smell days and what you do is you call
up the slaughterhouse and you say hey
can you can you [ __ ] cool it a little
bit up there we can smell it all the way
down here we can smell the murder this
way and then they actually sort of I
don't know what they do take a 15-minute
break from killing the stairs or
whatever I don't [ __ ] know I steer by
the way is a bull without balls I had no
idea what that was I knew what a cow was
I knew what a bull was I didn't know
what a steer was steers a bull without
balls and those are the things that they
they use
for all your steak and hamburger I
believe I don't think they use the cows
use the cows for the milk they use the
Bulls to [ __ ] the cows to make more cows
and to make more Bulls and then they cut
their balls off and they make them
steers is that how it works right did I
learn that and my travels out there on
the road correct me if I'm wrong they're
southerners what are you asking me
because I'm from the south
yes you Pig [ __ ] jackass answer the
question all right here we go
dear bill I recently moved to downtown
Denver from a from from Fort Collins a
small college town north of Denver the
only black people I had had been used to
seeing were either exchange students
from Africa or Colorado State football
basketball players my new home in Denver
is a neighborhood that is known for
having a high black population to cut to
the point I've noticed while driving
around my place that black people
generally younger black guys do not
respect jaywalking laws at all I noticed
that this I noticed this after the fifth
time in one day that a black dude had
walked right out into traffic expecting
that the drivers would hit their brakes
and wait for him to cross the street now
I see now I see this happen every day
when I got home I brought it to the
attention of my roommates and girlfriend
and they thought I was crazy but soon
enough they all began to notice this
phenomenon and now it's a big inside
joke amongst us all so I don't know if
you've seen that there are quite a few
popular YouTube videos that show exactly
what I'm talking about one video that I
think you may have talked about showed a
black guy danced his way into traffic
until an ice-cream truck put a stop to
that is it racist that I noticed this
also is this just a Denver thing or does
it happen elsewhere jaywalking happens I
think all over the world and every race
does it as far as I know this one is a
little complex because there's a lot of
levels to this because you don't seem
like you have hatred in your heart
and also I haven't been to your
neighborhood if that's what people do
you know then that's what they do there
I lived in New York City and we all do
it all everybody 80 year-old [ __ ]
women from the Aster family jaywalk
and then you know over to their [ __ ]
town car to go visit their bars of gold
everybody jaywalks so I wouldn't I
wouldn't yeah obviously black people
aren't the only ones who jaywalk but in
your neighborhood if that's what
everybody does I mean that's not racist
to notice that I think to just say that
it's just black people I don't you know
what this is these these are getting
these are getting difficult cuz I got to
hear what you're doing with that
information you know you did have your
little Klan moment where you convince
the people that you're living with I'm
telling you go out there go out there
and look at them and then they came back
oh we [ __ ] your rat now how offensive it
is it that just because you know you're
from Denver why am i giving you a
southern accent see we're all full of
[ __ ] here [ __ ] I just had a point that
what the hell was I gonna try to make
yeah I mean I'd have to know if you were
just saying like you know if you take it
to the level I guess where you get
you're going let you know oh you know
the obvious level to take this where it
would obviously be races if you were
just like we got to get we gotta get all
the black people out of this country
they're all these jaywalking sons of
[ __ ] they're ruined in this country
or uh you know I don't want my daughter
dating a black guy why cuz they're
jaywalking sons of [ __ ] of what I
mean I don't [ __ ] know if you just
sort of noticing this in you and you
think it's funny that they do this [ __ ]
kind of like when I do that older Asian
thing I don't have anything to get a
Asians or old people if you [ __ ]
around like no I mean it's probably
offensive like my older Asian thing
which I guess that that it might that
game is offensive to some people yeah is
it racist that you noticed I mean it did
happen
I guess it's when you start thinking
that that all black people in general
like Bill Cosby is walking out of his
mansion and Jay walks across the street
to I mean I don't know I don't know
where to go with that one yeah no but
I'll tell you this to everybody Jay
walks and I am one of the
major offenders of it I do it all the
[ __ ] time
all right I don't got [ __ ] time to
walk down to the goddamn corner I don't
understand what the [ __ ] point is I
get it look both ways and if there's
nothing coming then go but if
something's coming don't go I get that
all right jaywalking I think those laws
are basically invented they're basically
so they can keep traffic moving and B
don't have to clean up a lot of dead
people in the street because there's a
lot of bad drivers and there's also a
lot of people who can't see that well or
across the street correctly maybe that's
why I don't [ __ ] know all right now
we're into advice is this one of these
ones where I'm just reading too much
rather than riffing what is that what
the [ __ ] going on here you know what
I'm gonna talk about YouTube videos
maybe they'll [ __ ] stir up some sort
of some sort of comedy here I feel like
I'm gonna [ __ ] Meet the Press YouTube
videos check this one I remember a few
weeks ago when I showed that dude Johnny
Mack the QB doing all those trick shots
somebody made an answer video somebody
else threw his [ __ ] football helmet
into the ring some guy Alex I don't know
if I'm gonna say this right Tanny Alex
Tani's video this is what I got to say
about at least these trickshot Kings the
ones that are most impressive is when
they do more than one trick without an
edit those are the ones that I like but
uh you know other than that these are
pretty impressive so check that one out
this is a classic YouTube video woman
beats up boyfriend keeps yelling fight
back all these videos will be up on the
mmm podcast and I this is some inside
information that I'll give you I never
named names all right but there's a
friend of mine who wrote a very
successful movie after watching this
video all right and in this video there
is a woman beating the [ __ ] out of a guy
a big woman okay so think of some
comedies that came out in the last
[ __ ] what was it I think it was like
five years ago it came out and why don't
I just tell you the movies Norbit
the guy I know who wrote the movie wrote
the movie after seeing this video he
thought this video was [ __ ] hilarious
and said that's a movie and then he
wrote it and then it got made and I'm
ever standing there going wow it's that
[ __ ] easy you just have to sit down
and do the goddamn work you know all
right next one
magnetic kid what the [ __ ] is that did I
even watch that one seven-year-old kid
claims he's magnetic I somehow missed
that one drunk guy on the news you have
to see this is the best one of the week
I think as far as [ __ ] hilarity this
guy is out of his mind
and speaking of racing's this guy gets
real he's really drunk and he starts
talking about his neighbors he goes now
I'll tell you warning you right now I
never liked those people I'm I'm gonna
stay I'm gonna say something racist
right and he's so drunk he never gets
around to it but the one of the funniest
things of this video aside from the
unbelievably long pauses this guy takes
between talking is how the the reporter
keeps trying to give the guy the out
he's like did you start drinking because
you were so distraught from the fire and
the guys like no you know like I've been
drinking off I was drinking before the
fire during it and after it you know
that's basically his whole vibe now
here's a video people keep sending me I
don't know why people find this thing
funny I find the voice-over to be
unbelievably annoying
it says crazy nasty ass honey badger and
I guess it's making fun of all the
videos showing how badass the honey
badger is but this guy sounds like he's
doing a really bad impression of a
sitcom character that's gay and he just
he's annoying after a while
I'm conspiracy theorists out there New
World Order documentary we have and I
actually got this one Chevy 1991 s10
commercial that one of the people I
follow on YouTube he does a bunch of
really good Zeppelin covers and he
throws up random videos every once in a
while so I saw it on his channel I was
both for sure
I believe his name is B ei you just type
in that and then look up Zeppelin if
you're a drummer he [ __ ] kills a
bunch of different Zeppelin tracks and
alright those are the YouTube videos for
this week and uh do I have anything else
to talk about I think I'm just going to
[ __ ] advise and then we'll wrap this
goddamn thing up we will wrap it up oh
this week by the way I'm gonna be in
Miami all right I'm gonna be in Miami at
the the [ __ ] [ __ ] fest theater where
the hell am I gonna be hang on a second
let me let me get the information for
you right you just sit tight you sit
tight and your goddamn cubicle alright
start [ __ ] scratching your chin as
you're looking at those spreadsheets
like that's odd
alright I'm at the New World Symphony
517th Street Miami Beach Florida also
for those of you in Utah I add us I
added a date in March March 18th and
March 19th I'm gonna be at wise guys in
West Valley City Utah probably gonna
hang around for another day to go
[ __ ] skiing oh I know what I want to
tell you guys I finally committed to the
sport of hockey told you I've been
playing ice hockey out here and all I
had I had the helmet with the full cage
in the front because who's kidding who
my dream of making it to the NHL died
sometime I believe about 1984 I was
never good I always sucked so I've been
playing I helmet I have the full face
mask and I had the gloves stick skates
obviously that's all I had and I gotta
tell you as a 42 year old man falling
down on the [ __ ] ice that is not a
good feeling so I finally just said to
hell with it and I went out and I bought
all the gear head to toe I have all the
[ __ ] pads and it made made all the
difference in the world dude you go down
you don't feel anything you don't feel
anything it's [ __ ] tremendous it's
like falling falling on it not pillows
but it's it's the [ __ ] so so anyway so
what I've been doing is you know I hate
going to the [ __ ] gym so I either
take my dog for a hike or recently for
cardio's that they have you know they
have
look skating things so I'll go down
there like a [ __ ] pedophile no 42
year old single white male never married
no kids I swear to God I won't even look
at a child when I am in there
I won't I [ __ ] I just skate around
and I [ __ ] mind my own business so
anyway I go down there and I basically
work on [ __ ] that I suck at that you can
work on and during a public skating
thing which is basically I suck at
stopping on my right side so I just
started working on that and I can turn
around to skate backwards but I'm not
good I'm more left-handed than I am
right handed so I'm not good yet I shoot
the puck right-handed I'm [ __ ] so I
can't turn around to the right side good
so the only way you improve in life is
if you attack your weaknesses so I start
learning it right and I'm crossing over
and everything's going great and then
what happens I get a little cocky oh
right and I'm [ __ ] my version of
flying I'm probably going three-quarters
of the speed that that I can skate and I
[ __ ] turn around and dude I don't
know what the [ __ ] happened because I
you know I'll fall but I can fall
gracefully at this point this was like I
had a beginner fall and I was going
backwards at about 17 miles an hour and
I didn't fall on my side I didn't I
didn't get my hands down nothing I felt
I fell like a [ __ ] tree and I landed
right on my ass and then I got my right
elbow down at the last second so my head
didn't hit the ice but my brain still
smacked and like I was dizzy when I got
up a dude I swear to god I don't know
how I didn't break my tailbone I [ __ ]
like my ass was killing me I had to say
I skated off the ice that was it I was
done I went off the ice and I sat down
and I collected myself you know and I
had snow all over my backside oh I
missed the best part and when I fell
down and I [ __ ] went to try just kind
of stayed there for half a second like
that I just break my [ __ ] tailbone
did I really just do that and I and I
didn't feel any sort of you know pain
beyond I just busted my ass on the ice
so as I roll over some like 11 year old
kid
spy and does the Simpson haha and then
keeps going I gotta admit I didn't get
even get mad at him I was just like I
said I know it I know and I know it and
then I got up and it was until I was
driving home that that kid actually
annoyed me and I dreamed of
cross-checking him into the glass now
which is which is childish but uh yes
I'm playing again this week and
definitely having a good time it's so
much better than going to the gym and I
having fallen on the ice there by myself
I have a whole new respect for like
contact sports like people who play him
at like you know professional [ __ ]
levels or even just pickup games like
you know I was seriously like there was
like Idol to collect myself like I said
like I can't imagine doing that [ __ ] for
a [ __ ] living I mean skating is hard
enough forget about some guy trying to
knock you over when you're not looking
it's just it's unbelievable I'm [ __ ]
believable so it's unbelievable I
couldn't believe it I'm bored with it
already
alright let's let's read some advice and
then I'm getting the getting the [ __ ]
out of here
um by the way recently I've actually
thought I've considered about having
some advertising here on the podcast and
I know what you guys are thinking oh gee
here he goes he's gonna sell out man
you're absolutely right I am gonna sell
out you know what do you think I want to
keep it real and stay broke I'm not
broke I'm doing alright but give me a
[ __ ] break okay eventually people I'm
not gonna want to jump on a goddamn
airplane okay and I don't want to charge
you [ __ ] anything you know so I've been
thinking about it so but I think I can
still do it in a creative cool way where
I'll just have advertisers on here of
[ __ ] that I like drum companies booze
you know [ __ ] like that as long as I can
read it and make fun of the copy I will
do it and I'll charge everybody a dollar
75 for episode I don't know I'm gonna
try to figure something out alright
let's go to advice spill advice so for
the last five years I've been teaching
guitar lessons full-time at a very large
music school in Chicago
there are over a hundred music teachers
at the school with about 5,000 students
every session half of those students are
under 18 the school has been around for
over 50 years and is globally recognized
see if I can figure that out mm-hmm
Oh Chicago I don't know that must mean
guess Berkeley now I get an email from
the new director of the school saying
all of the staff are required to get
their thumbs scanned by some company
called biometric what biometric scans
your thumbs into their watch system we
all already had background checks done
when we were hired but now they argue
that we need to have this done
apparently all the public school
teachers in their entire city are being
forced to do this as well basically
anyone who is around any younger who is
around any younger please people please
proofread your [ __ ] you make me sound
dumb I'm already dumb enough basically
anyone who is around any younger people
oh for a profession is now mandated by
their employee to get in this creepy
biometric system you see this [ __ ] have
you guys noticed this all this [ __ ]
screaming and yelling we do during every
single election that comes around to
pick the Democrat or the other
Republican it doesn't make a difference
because when the real [ __ ] goes down
like approving giving biometrics the
right to do this we don't get to vote on
this they don't even tell us about it
they just go it's a law it's mandatory
you have to do this anyways he says I
don't have anything to hide but the
mental picture of all of us
harmless musicians lining up like
[ __ ] cattle having some stormtrooper
[ __ ] scanning my thumbprint into
some supercomputer where it will stay
forever is really depressing obviously
this is all done in the name of
air-quote Ekta children but at what cost
here's my question for you I feel like
this is my moment to take a stand should
I make a deal a big deal about this and
try to rally all the other teachers to
fight this or will I just look like I
have something to hide it is really
really hard to get a job at this school
so I'm scared to make waves do you feel
like
this protects kids from creeps I should
mention that in the school's 50-year
history no incident of a teacher student
misconduct has been recorded everyone
knows that pedophiles can't play an
instrument lol and do you think they are
making priests get thumb scans I [ __ ]
bet not all joking aside I'm really
bothered by this situation what should I
do bill I don't know why the first thing
I would do is I would talk to other
teachers and see how they feel about it
I think that's complete horseshit
dude they have been basically working
their way towards this since they first
came up with photo IDs and social
security numbers and all of that [ __ ]
it's all done under the whole guise of
organization in your own [ __ ] safety
and it's complete horseshit it has to do
with them eventually trying to have a
very few people be able to make the
decisions for all of us that's basically
what's going on ok and the more
information they have about you the
easier it is to be able to find you I
mean think about that [ __ ] they're gonna
have your thumbprint they know what your
[ __ ] fingerprint looks like alright
they're gonna have an ability to freeze
your [ __ ] bank account and your cell
phone as a goddamn microchip in it ok so
the second day I mean this is like end
of days [ __ ] and they got these [ __ ]
robots that they've been working on that
can outperform human beings I'm telling
you our days are [ __ ] numbered they
out on Jeopardy the other day they had
two human beings playing against a
[ __ ] computer
those two people they're helping human
beings get phased out you should see I'm
not competing against a [ __ ] computer
so you can figure out how it does
against me and you can figure the
computers weaknesses and strong points
so it can come back with even more game
and you can pump it back with more
[ __ ] information so eventually I
become [ __ ] useless unless of course
I know how to build a robot or know how
to grease its [ __ ] joints yeah dude I
think yeah I think it would be a very
noble thing if you complained about that
I think people need
to complain more I'm guilty of it I
[ __ ] rant here on this podcast but
I've never been to a protest but I don't
think that it's right that they that
they pass a lot like whether you agree
with that or not that's not something
that they should be able to pass without
the voice of the people we should be
able to vote on something like that
that's [ __ ] ridiculous
I just find out for my account the other
day after years of saying I'm not doing
my [ __ ] online because I don't want to
put all that information online I now
have no option I have to do it online
you know I don't want to put all my
[ __ ] information online my tax ID
numbers my social security numbers your
honor you [ __ ] mind you're letting
people in to your entire financial
history you're letting your whole
[ __ ] god knows what they can do with
that and they can ruin you all right all
I'm doing is bitching here but now
that's [ __ ] really that's [ __ ] creepy
as hell I would talk to other people be
like dude hey you know what do you think
about this you know sort of get it going
you know just like how they started the
revolution in this country those
redcoats right the kind of dicks yeah I
don't like em either
all right question number two hey Bill
this has been bothering me for a while
now and I'm not sure what to do I'm 19
years old I go to UMass Amherst oh geez
dude that place is insane do you guys
still party the time out generation do
you still party the way they used to
where they would actually have
fatalities at that school people used to
ride the elevators there was that
classic urban myth about those kids
bringing the cow up to the roof of the
building and they didn't know how to get
it off so they just pushed it off the
side and it exploded into hamburger
heaven anyways I had a girlfriend my
first semester of college that was still
in high school we both knew that I was
going to that we both knew that I was
going far away and we but we agreed that
we would stay together however I guess
her feelings changed and she wanted to
be single I was devastated when she
broke up with me and I've been really
down because she was the first
girlfriend I had that I really liked and
I wasn't just trying to get laid
actually like this girl so after a few
weeks I found out she was hooking up
with this kid that I considered to be a
friend boy because we had been hanging
out over the summer and partying
together what's [ __ ] up about the
whole situation is that this isn't the
first time this guy has done this to me
all right you know what I just thought
of when I read that sentence was what
was the fourth name of that movie dead
presidents
you know when the dude comes back into
the pool hall with the stick and he
beats the [ __ ] out of Terrence Howard
right that's
I'm not saying to do that but that's the
first movie scene that came to my head
anyways at the end of my senior year I
broke up with a different girl and this
kid was hooking up with her about a
month later I let that one slide that's
your fault Dennis because he said
because again I didn't really give a
[ __ ] about any other girl friends I had
before this previous one I don't want to
be a crazy ex-boyfriend that gets
defensive over girls that no longer like
him but should I or should I not tell
this kid to back off and stop going
after my ex-girlfriends you definitely
need to have a talk with that dude you
need to clear the air with them and and
then you need to stop [ __ ] with them
that's what I would do and I would go
somewhere along the lines of describing
him is like you ever see those little
fish that swim under the big fish you
know they're not plankton I don't know
what they [ __ ] they are they swim under
the whales you know just ask him it's
like dude do you have an ability to get
[ __ ] without drafting behind me like
somebody in the Tour de France you know
if there was like [ __ ] at the finish
line the [ __ ] is wrong with you you know
I don't know don't listen to me on how
to say that stuff because I say [ __ ] a
lot and I'm gonna angry dude you'll end
up getting into a fistfight but I yeah I
would definitely say something to the
kid
oh you don't be funny if you called him
up like I don't know where you're from
you know just say you're from just say
you're from LA just call him say hey
listen just to let you know I've been
recently hooking up with this chick from
San Diego you know I just want to let
you know you know send your picture just
to show you the next person that you're
gonna be [ __ ] because evidently you
love my sloppy seconds
you know you [ __ ] pervert hey you
gave for me or something do you just
want to be where my dick has been you
know the love of God go get yourself a
boyfriend there you go hit him with the
homophobia that's a
not that I advocate homophobia but when
you use it it can be your friend ah
nothing he makes sense all right bill
hey Bill I'm 24 and have four kids she
was at the [ __ ] 1800s what do you got
what do you got some [ __ ] do you need
some farmhand sir somebody go clean out
the silo or fill it up oh good lord
you guys make your own clothes I'm 24
and I have four kids I'm married I feel
bad for this guy should make fun home I
work for public utilities doing very
hard manual labor and I work hard for my
money which goes straight to my wife and
four kids basically when politicians run
for office and they try to stand on the
shoulders of hardworking Americans this
is the guy right here this is the guy
that like Sam Elliott talks about
speaking and I recently saw one of those
course commercials we've seen that the
Rocky Mountains go down this country
like a backbone and we make our beer the
way the [ __ ] we want to and that's
what's having a backbone is all about
you're gonna have a backbone to make a
lite beer that looks and tastes like
piss a watered-down shitty beer it comes
from the backbone rocky mountains you
know something I think whenever you have
a [ __ ] product you know one of the red
flags is you get Sam Elliot to do the
voice-over you know because you're like
oh my god people are gonna see right
through the fact dead I mean come on
people Korres that's one of those beers
when like you're hungover that you
actually drink that's like vitamin water
for an alcoholic
they're trying to tie it into the
[ __ ] Rocky Mountains I mean I know I
know they get their [ __ ] water from
the Rocky Mountains go down this country
like a backbone
give me some of that skull Baghdad Jesus
anyways where the [ __ ] am i how the [ __ ]
that even start talking about that the
other day I got a call from work the
other day I got a call from her okay
let's let's let's let's
let's reset this up again the guy's 24
years old he has 17 kids now he has four
kids he's married
works of Public Utilities does very hard
manual labor he works his [ __ ] ass
off and all his money goes straight to
his [ __ ] wife and his kids all right
the other day I got a call from her at
work and she told me to meet her at the
doctor's office because she doesn't like
taking the kids to the doctor alone when
I get there she starts yelling at me as
usual red flag and they and then said
then she said all you know how to do is
work so why don't you just go back to
work and saying all I do is pick up
after you and the kids and basically
calling me a loser for working and
making money I'm doing my best to
provide for my kids she takes my money
she spends my money on stupid [ __ ] we've
been married for a year and four months
now but you got four kids did you have
quadruplets or what happened I don't
know bill I just like to hear your take
on the situation and give me some advice
all right okay no Jesus here we go
all right all right first things first I
don't know what you said before she said
all you know how to do is work so why
don't you go back to work that could
have been anything from her actually
being a jerk to her saying yeah Phillip
has a cold and you said yeah which one's
Phillip we've got so many [ __ ] kids
which one which one is easy the little
rusty haired one bet she did you go back
to work you know if she said it like
that then and what can you do but it
doesn't seem I don't know the fact that
she's saying all I do is pick up after
you and the kids this is what you need
to do the worst thing that you can do
when you want somebody to hear your
point is to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] like me
it's like when I want to approach that
lady at the bank
you know I I she didn't hear what I was
saying because they she's you know uh
she's a [ __ ]
all right whose kid no but beyond that
was I was a dick to her
so no one's gonna listen to you if
you're a dick so if you really if you
want to stay with this woman right
you're going through a rough pairing
your relationship what you have to do is
you got to walk away from that situation
you know go scream into a pillow all the
[ __ ] that you want to say to her or go
yell at your windshield as you drive
around the block 15 [ __ ] times a
couple of drinks whatever you got to do
unwind and this is how I do it because I
have a brutal temper and just write down
on a piece of paper what you want to
[ __ ] convey all right and then
practice it I know this sounds crazy to
two people who don't have this problem
but that's what I have to do because
I'll sit there and like that Bank thing
I tried to practice it my first attempt
at practicing I would start off slow and
eventually get pissed all over again I'd
be like hey listen I noticed that when
you went in you know you open your car
door into my car and then you came out
and then you did it again and it's like
what the [ __ ] you know okay wait I can't
do that all right start over bill and
each time I would get further and
further to the end so that's what you
have to do with this person you have to
sit down power in 12 minutes how [ __ ]
long is this podcast you have to sit
down with her and just be like look I
mean I don't know what you're just say
listen we have four kids that's the
situation you know the place is gonna be
a mess and I am working okay obviously
I'm not giving you what you need what
what more do you need from me okay let
her that's it probably a good way all
right we need to talk you seemed really
upset with me blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
what more do you need from me than what
I'm doing all right since she sees that
you relaxed you're gonna hear what the
hell she wants to say then when she says
what she has to say you know fair enough
all right here's here's what I need from
you all right and then in a nice way you
got to tell her to stop spending all
your money on stupid [ __ ] all right
that's what you got to do and I'm
telling you the key when you're [ __ ]
trying to make some headway in your
relationship is with the woman is you
can't
lose your [ __ ] cool all right and
they will if you back them into a corner
sometimes when they're doing something
wrong cuz if humans they're gonna do
something wrong when you back them into
the corner and they did something wrong
watch out if they start attacking you
all right with [ __ ] that has nothing to
do what you're arguing about like you're
arguing about you know you know whatever
you like you you [ __ ] she keeps
leaving the TV on and going to bed and
it's on all night she's [ __ ] whatever
whatever the [ __ ] that that causes the
the electric bill to go up if all of a
sudden she starts going well you know
you just man cuz you you know you're
just short or she attacks you for that
or some other [ __ ] or just you're
just a [ __ ] [ __ ] right there she
just abandoned her argument and what
she's doing now is she's just trying to
make you mad so that she can steer the
argument into some other [ __ ] or
just hopefully get you to say something
so [ __ ] up that it it just totally
camouflages you know the [ __ ] that
she did to start the [ __ ] argument
basically so just keep it cool you got
to sit down you got it you do it you got
four girl you got four kids with this
with this girl yeah you're attached at
the hip with this woman okay so what you
want to do is try to have a good time
you're a good guy you're working your
[ __ ] ass off okay
she needs to appreciate that and she has
to appreciate that you know you know
what do you want to do you want to
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
he didn't want to walk around picking up
Spongebob Squarepants stuffed animals
all day you know you got to be like
sweetheart you had four [ __ ] kids see
this is why I'm not good at it
sweetheart you had four [ __ ] kids the
[ __ ] do you think was gonna happen you
know get you tubes tied quit bitching to
me see that's the first pass that's the
first way I would say it anybody get to
the end you just say listen you know I
love you you love me we have four
beautiful kids we have to work together
it's definitely a trying time and being
this young with all these kids but blah
blah blah blah and I'm telling you your
life will be like it'll be better it'll
be better if you work it out but the
worst thing you want to do is come and
hurt after you've had a few pops and
said listen let me tell you something
you dumb [ __ ]
alright I'm the backbone of this [ __ ]
country you don't want to come at her
that way all right you stupid [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] working my balls off
why don't you go out there and that
goddamn [ __ ] oil rig all day you know
once you go down the pharmacy get on the
[ __ ] pill maybe you won't have to be
picking up so much [ __ ] all right
or they'll let me know to pull out you'd
say dumb [ __ ] like that
you know and then you're gonna have it
you and have a [ __ ] horrific
relationship you don't wanna do that so
that's it that's the podcast for this
week everybody and as I mentioned I am
up on Twitter now and actually enjoying
it I have made peace with the with the
tweeting you know I feel like right now
I feel like a I felt like Johnny Damon
when he went to the Yankees that's a
thrashing - twittering but and now I'm
[ __ ] you know shaved my beard got a
haircut
oh yeah he's gonna try to come in and
contribute on Twitter wherever I can
I know it's not that bad it's not the
best just typical me I am I'm an old
soul I'm a crabby 80 year old as a 42
year old I am
I look new I don't like it I didn't like
Facebook I still don't really like it
but I'm at the mercy of you guys you
guys all go to Twitter with the [ __ ] am
I supposed to do you know I stayed on
MySpace as long as I could I felt like I
was in a ghost town like some old minor
town that dried up and I was just
sitting there listening to the rusty
hinges you know is the door swing swung
back and forth up Jesus bill we get it
stop being so [ __ ] dramatic you're a
Twitter in fear you're a tweeter yeah
that's it that's the podcast for this
week you guys all have a y'all have a
wonderful week and go [ __ ] yourself all
right
[Music]
45 well
singing illuminate the Main Street
cinema right
[Music]